welcome to the show everybody thanks for
watching or listening however it is that
you're consuming this thank you for
doing that
if you are watching you can tell already
that I have chosen an especially scenic
spot for my car cast which by the way is
what I'm calling it now my car cast this
morning I'm in a parking garage right
next to an overflowing trash can which
I'm not sure if you can see that in the
shot or not but it's you know I just I
thought I'd really like some beautiful
scenery this time I'm mixing it up a
little bit now there's a protest taking
shape for next Monday that I want to
talk about it some called the sex ed sit
out
sex ed sit out say that five times fast
and parents across the country are being
encouraged by the organizers of this
protest to keep their kids home for the
day in order to make a statement about
the degenerate disgusting perverse sex
ed classes that are so common in schools
nowadays I think it's a great idea I
like the idea of the protest my only
problem with it is that I think it's a
little bit too short I think it should
last a little longer like for instance
it should last forever
maybe I mean yeah keep your kids home
from public school but don't send them
back the next day never send them back I
think is what that's that's the protest
that we really need to organize but this
is a good first step it's a baby step
and that's good and it's very needed
it's warranted it's about time that
parents are taking a stand against this
because sex ed has really devolved in
our country into an abomination and no
age group is safe anymore it used to be
at least that the degenerates who come
up with these with these sex ed
curricula they they would at least hold
off until a kid was 13 14 15 but now
they don't even do that anymore so kids
in the 8th you know its second third
grade sometimes younger sometimes
kindergarten they're being indoctrinated
brainwashed into far-left gender theory
and everything else and as the kids grow
older the sex ed becomes more and more
orna graphic more and more disturbing
because what we're doing with kids what
what they're doing with kids in public
school it's not they're not educating
them with sex ed this is about grooming
they're grooming them much like a sex
predator does with a child they're
grooming conditioning the children and
so once they get into middle school in
high school then they're gonna start
school start working with Planned
Parenthood no problem there right I mean
that's not like that's a controversial
thing to do Planned Parenthood they only
kill three hundred and thirty thousand
babies a year but yeah bring them into
the school why not and so Planned
Parenthood comes in hands out condoms
and then the kids are taught about sex
toys and masturbation anal sex oral sex
bondage I mean these are all the things
that the kid that the schools are
presenting to children now when I talk
about this sometimes people will accuse
me of being opposed to sex ed in general
they said well it sounds like you don't
want any kind of sex ed Oh have you
picked up on that yeah that's actually
exactly how I feel you're exactly right
I want there should be zero sex ed in
the schools zero yes a child should
learn about the basics of Human
Reproduction a kid should know where
babies come from when it's the right age
to broach that subject that should be
broached but you can cover human biology
in biology class and you can cover
Anatomy when human anatomy comes up so
that's and that's what those are the
realms where this discussion should be
had and it should never go beyond that
just present the basic facts of
reproduction leave it at that that's
what the schools should do they should
not take one step beyond the basic facts
of human reproduction public schools
ought to be a place of just pure
academics in terms of the things that
they're learning it should just be
academic and nothing else
the stuff that they learned in sex ed
now this is not academic its doctrinal
doctrinal as in these are doctrines that
are being passed on to our kids the
schools have it's not that the schools
have an idea about the kind of knowledge
that they want kids to have or the sort
of information that they want kids to
know that of course is fine no problem
there
the problem is when schools get into
their heads or get an idea of the kind
of people they want kids to be and to
become and the sorts of belief systems
and value systems that they want kids to
hold when they get into that that's when
we have problems that's when you you you
go from from science like with sex and
talking about reproduction that's just a
matter of well here's some information
here's some here's some information that
you should know and just leave it at
that
but when you go beyond that then you you
you've left science and then you
ventured into the realm of philosophy
and so these sex ed classes are really
more like philosophy classes really
strange bizarre gross philosophy classes
because it's a strange bizarre gross
philosophy but that's what it is uh so
yes it may be a teacher's job to tell a
kid about Anatomy or biology or whatever
else but it's not her job to give a
sermon on her personal views about human
sexuality or the proper context for it
she may hold the personal conviction
that sex is an appropriate recreational
activity for a fourteen-year-old she's
wrong about that but the fact that she's
wrong isn't even the point
the fact is it's a personal conviction
it's not a scientific fact that's just
how you feel that's your value system it
has no place in the schools
has no place in the classroom leave it
at home you can teach your own kids that
God helped them but you can't teach my
kid that see the the left insists upon
separation of church and state but what
we come to realize is that what they
really mean is separation of the
Christian church and state but their own
church their own doctrines they very
much want that in the schools because
they do have their own they have their
Church of self worship their church of
which is really as I've said before
leftism is really secular Satanism so
it's really just a secular kind of a
secularized Church of Satan here's what
they ascribed to do what that will shall
be the whole of the law that is there
that's the Satanic motto just do what
you want you know and that's also the
model of liberalism because it's
Satanism and again they're they're free
to to have that view but that's a
religious view doesn't belong in the
school's gender fluidity is not science
it's a doctrine now the fact that men
have penises women have vaginas that's
science
and yeah we should tell our kids that
but the idea that well a man could have
a penis but he feels like a woman and so
in some mysterious incomprehensible way
he even though physically he's a man he
still is in some way a woman because he
feels that way and is I mean this is an
intensely spiritual view it's also
intensely wrong and insane but it's
spiritual it is not scientific it's not
physical it's not academic in the
slightest doesn't belong in the schools
the idea that safe sex is better than
abstinence that's a doctrine that's your
personal view not science doesn't belong
in the schools the idea that
masturbation is healthy and natural
that's a doctrine not science doesn't
belong in the schools
these things are doctrines now to be
clear I'm actually I'm not advocating
for abstinence education here so-called
AB much of the debate about sex ed is
well should it be absent in sex ed or
should it be this kind of sex edge it's
basically hedonistic sex ed or absent in
sex ed now if I had to choose between
the two definitely abstinence is better
but the answer is neither the correct
answer is neither because yeah I don't
want the schools teaching my kid how to
have sex or wind to have sex I also
don't want the school's teaching my kid
how to avoid sex that's not something
that I want to entrust to the school
system that's not an appropriate
conversation for a stranger to have with
my child okay for an adult who works in
the school system it's on either end of
that spectrum it's not an appropriate
conversation for you to be having with
my kid and you know the issue with
abstinence education is that abstinence
education has to be grounded in
something deeper than just scare tactics
and STD statistics there's a reason why
you know there are parents who in their
homes they try to teach abstinence and
to tell their kids oh no you know you
don't want to have sex at this age and
often times that that that message just
falls on deaf ears or the kids listen to
it and it just dissipates very quickly
and I think oftentimes the the reason is
that it's the message has to be grounded
in something more than that you can't
really give that message in a totally
secular way so for me when I'm when I'm
communicating this message to my kids
when they're old enough to hear it the
message will be grounded in my views on
marriage on love on loyalty self-control
virtue and faith now I fully admit now
the left won't admit that their views on
sex are you know religious in nature but
they are I fully it I fully admit that
my my view
unsex are informed by my religious
convictions and I'd make no apology for
that and that's why if I'm trying to
explain to my kids why they shouldn't
have sex before marriage I mean I you
know like yeah I can tell them about
STDs I can tell them about different
things like I can give them all the
practical reasons but the message will
it won't be as effective if I don't also
mention or if it's not in a deeper sense
grounded in the gospel you know where
there are a lot of reasons not to have
sex before marriage but the real reason
the fundamental reason is that it's a
sin it's wrong it's not what God wants
you to do and so if you're trying to
tell your kids about sex and it
discourage them from having it but
you're not saying that it's not gonna
work you haven't given them enough of an
incentive
you just haven't so but no I I'm not
saying that the school should be telling
that to kids I know I don't want leave
that to me I can do it it's not for you
so it's very simple how much sexual
guidance and instruction should the
government schools offer our kids none
what percentage of a child's government
education should be comprised of sexual
enlightenment 0% how many times in a
given day should the schools talk to the
kids about sex toys or lubricant zero
times zero point zero never never bring
it up it's not for you to do so instead
of arguing about what the schools should
tell kids on the subject of sex maybe we
consider the possibility that a
government-controlled mass-produced and
disseminated curriculum about sex and
intimacy isn't necessarily the best way
to handle such a profound and personal
and important and intimate subject it's
not the way to do it
this isn't about hiding kids from sex
it's not about you know I'm not saying
that we should censor you know with
learning art that we should put bars
over the penis and the and the breasts
and in a work of art or anything like
that I'm not saying that what I'm saying
is that a a a lesson about sex that is
rooted in someone's doctrine and
personal convictions about the proper
context for sex you know the proper
moral view of sex that message does not
belong in the schools on either end of
the spectrum just leave it alone you
know it's interesting that if if an
adult came up to your child in any other
context like let's say at the playground
or something came up to your 13 year old
lady 13 olds probably not the playground
but whatever if you're walking down the
street and an adult some strange adult
comes up to your 13 year old and says
hey let's let's let's talk about are you
sexually active let's talk about sex
toys all right here do you want a condom
remember practice safe sex
if adult did that in that context what
would you do you probably punch them in
the face and then call the police and
you'd be justified in doing so on both
counts but we've decided that
okay for teachers to do now this subject
belongs to parents it is their domain it
is not domain of the schools and I know
I know I often hear it argued that well
what if pet what if parents aren't
talking about it what if the parents
aren't doing their job you know what
what if the parents were a lot of
repairs refused to talk to their kids
about sex because it's an awkward
conversation well that's unfortunate
it's it truly is unfortunate that so
many parents in our culture refuse to do
their job
but the school system is not a surrogate
mother the school system is not a foster
home it's not even a daycare center or
it shouldn't be these people that you
send your kids to school for they are
not stand-ins for parents so there are
certain things that if the parent isn't
going to do well then those things just
aren't getting done I guess sadly I mean
I also happen to believe very strongly
that it's a parent's job to instill a
moral foundation in the child and to
bring them up in the faith and in the
gospel I mean I firmly believe that
that's a parent so that should be a
parent's primary job is to do that but
if the parents not gonna do it school
system can't step in at least a
government school system can't sadly in
that case that's a job that probably
just isn't going to get done there are
certain
that either the parent does it or really
nobody does it or the kid just figures
it out on his own which is not ideal but
it's even less ideal to take this
subject from the home and to place it in
the hands of the state because that's
what we've done and one more thought
about that very quickly because right if
the parents won't do it then what
happens well the kids just learn it from
each other
right they they especially when it comes
to sex they're just gonna pick it up
from the internet and from each other
and from peer culture and they'll learn
it that way and so some people will
argue that well you know you can't have
that I mean if it's like if the parents
won't do it then they learn it from the
peers I mean then yeah you got to have
the school step in because it's better
for them to hear it from the schools
than from their peers but as I've
already said it's still not the school's
job but even aside from that the the
message about sex the sex ed in the
schools has become so vulgar and debased
and just devoid of any kind of sense of
maturity or responsibility that there's
really no difference between what they
would hear from their sex ed teacher in
ninth grade and what they would hear
from their ninth grade classmate you
might they might as well just hear it
from the from the kids at that point my
point is it's not like the schools have
taken this subject and elevated it and
done something more mature and
responsible with it then what then what
the classmates would already do the
school's message is basically yeah if
you want to have sex get out go have sex
it's great just put on a condom first
well that's what that's the kids the
kids don't need to hear that from the
school they'll just hear that from each
other so
by this kind of by removing any sense of
morality or anything from the message of
sex
they've also removed any justification
for the sex ed programs even existing in
the first place
so let's just get rid of them teach the
kids the ABCs one two threes you know
have them read Shakespeare do all that
stuff science okay great
the moment you pull out the condoms
you know you veered way way way off
track but of course I'm saying all this
I realize it doesn't matter the schools
have become more and more doctrinal as
time has gone on and that's not gonna
change so it's great if you send your
kids to public school it's great that
you're taking a stand if you are taking
a stand I would definitely recommend it
but I think ultimately the only answer
in the end is just to get our kids away
from this system because it's just it's
not gonna get any better sadly and I'll
leave it there on a hopeful note have a
great day everyone I'll talk to you
tomorrow